they got unlocked on us
engine's been hit get us out of here
[Music]
at cd projekt red we dedicate ourselves
to telling immersive stories
yet with every new project we set out to
make our games bigger
more complex deeply engaging
come on v let's get you cyberpunk 2077
marries exploration of a vast open world
with kinetic combat
story changing player choices and robust
character development
all to bring you into our vision of the
dark future
if you ever feel like a city doesn't
give you a choice
you either burn alive in it or you never
existed at all
the year is 2077 an economic crisis
culminating in nuclear conflict has left
america in pieces
with most of the continent degenerating
into lawless war zones
people from all over have converged on
the already overcrowded
night city one of the world's last great
megalopolises
a hub amassing the best in resources and
know-how
and home to manufacturers of
cutting-edge technologies
night city continues to offer the
promise of a civilized future
what no no this isn't happening oh
but it is but in the city streets
a merciless struggle for power rages
gangs corporate agents hustlers
religious cultists
politicians and all manner of criminals
strive
to outplay one another ordinary people
get caught in the crossfire
looking for justice in night city i seek
revenge
much more feasible here
in this world consumed by never-ending
conflict
sometimes only an outsider will get the
job done
elizabeth tells me you have answers for
us i'm all
ears and that's you an urban mercenary
a cyber-enhanced gun for hire you seem
to understand each other
take this too as a mercenary you swear
no allegiance
you've chosen the outlaw life and trust
that your abilities will carry you up
night city's ruthless
underground social ladder night city
that's it right there to thrive as a
merc you need the right combination of
gear
skills and reputation dex had a load to
say about you
i hope he wasn't overselling with the
money you earn
you can turn yourself into a living
weapon buying guns and enhancements
as you roam the city's streets you gain
the experience you need to upgrade
abilities
and acquire perks combine the right
skills and gear to create a gunslinger
within human reflexes
a stealthy netrunner with command of all
surrounding tech
[Music]
or practically anyone in between
[Music]
in cyberpunk 2077 you steal a prototype
biochip that can set you up for life
being filthy rich when it's sealed
container is ruptured
the only way to prevent the biochip from
failing is to slot it into your head
it turns out it contains the digitized
soul of johnny silverhand
a dead rocker boy with violence on his
mind means to say there's an actual
terrorist in my head right now he's out
for revenge
aims to bring down the mega corp that
made the chip do whatever it takes to
stop him
defeat him what is in your head can
shift the balance of power in night city
the high and mighty will do anything to
lay their hands on it
told you i'd end you someday
the choices you make will shape your
story and determine how events
unfold you gotta take them down that's
why we're here
but not everything in night city is a
matter of life and death
sometimes it's about style choosing your
look
your ride your pastime who's at your
side
choosing how you spend your dirty money
welcome to the next generation of open
world adventure
immerse yourself in cyberpunk 2077
[Music]
uh
you